well I love The Addams Family and I love
you both as Gomez and fester so good I'm
just so curious you know when you you
take on iconic roles that people love so
much are you excited are there a bit of
nerves Fred
uh complete enthusiasm and excitement I
couldn't wait to start I loved every
second doing it
well as I was acting in it I had the
feeling of like in my head going like I
cannot believe there's a camera and I'm
being Uncle Fester
I couldn't get over it I'm still not
over it yeah I was over the moon man I
was like uh like I said as a kid I used
to watch the Adam family when it was a
black and white yeah and uh just to be
able to step into this into this Tim
Burke moral and to be this Gomez man I I
couldn't ask for anything better in my
career
you know these are such iconic
characters but at least what's so cool
is you're bringing to like this iconic
couple Gomez and Morticia with Catherine
Zeta Jones what's it like working with
her
oh it was great man we had a we had a
real love for each other
um you know we would really look into
each other's eyes and we had a good
connection we had a really good
connection
I could feel the love there's a lot of a
lot of love with this couple oh yeah
it's steamy
um okay so this is something I've been
asking people the rest of the cast
Wednesday is essentially trying to solve
this mystery throughout the whole series
so if you had to solve a murder mystery
with one other person in the cast in
real life who would you pick who would
you trust to solve a mystery with
my brother
why Fred
well we're family we're family this is
true family he knows some of my secrets
and I know none of his secrets
and so he would be the guy we'll go to
I love that and Fred this is mutual that
is mutual that is mutual yeah I would
not asking I would not ask lurch
also like getting to you know if if I'm
with Gomez Gomez is so well dressed I
think he can get answers just on charm
not only that I could get us a table and
a good restaurant
yeah you totally could the hair the suit
everything
um I love that what you know I dress up
as Wednesday Adams all the time for
Halloween uh it's such a fun character
for me I grew up watching this character
in the 90s films what are you excited
for fans to see when it comes to this
version of Wednesday
I think exploring that character the
character of Wednesday that hasn't
happened before that like really deep
exploration into her family Dynamics how
she sees things and Jenna Ortega and you
know even as an actor brilliant her
version is brilliant so that to me is
like you know aside from the fact that
it's Tim Burton it looks cool sounds
cool uh but the focus of Wednesday I
really I'm a fan of yeah also you know
she's kind of a
in her own way of Misfit but yeah she's
very powerful very strong very
strong-minded
and she takes charge you know she does
she doesn't back down
from anyone yeah she's very Unapologetic
for how she feels about things and just
that's how I read that thank you very
much you did a good job Gomez
um so when it comes to Tim Burton I just
want to know I just hear what a nice guy
he is you know he's this iconic director
this Mastermind in the horror genre
what's like working with him
man
uh
great I mean you know Tim Burton is so
grounded you know he he knows what he's
doing he knows the look he understands
everything I mean I was just like watch
him
because because I felt that man I'm
working with an icon and his own right
and I just want to see everything that
he does and how he does it and how he
flows
that's it that's it I love that he's
also very uh casual oh yeah he I think
that's like a secret ingredient that he
just keeps everything relaxed there's a
very sort of like calm feeling on set
that I think make brings out the best in
people yeah very grounded yeah I love
that guys so nice getting to talk to you
congrats on the series I think people
are gonna flip out over it's so good
thank you